这点你喜欢哪些作家？
实话实说啊，
就是文化底蕴看的书比较少，
我印象当中就是能让我记得起来的，
值得我推荐大家去看的书寥寥无几，
可能比如说余华老师，
他写的时候，
真的我推荐大家都去看一看啊，
我感觉他是一个活得很知行合一的人，
他真的是一个很真诚的人吧，
你有时候听他采访，
就余华老师他本身这个人，
他真的很通透，
很真诚，
你们有没有这种感觉吧，
可能人和人的感觉是微妙的，
反正我能捕捉到的，
我觉得余华老师身上那个点我就特别喜欢。
还有一个呢，
就是以前我年轻的时候，
大概读初中的时候，
我看过一部长篇的小说，
有就现在大家伙要想看长篇的小说的话，
确实是比较费时间啊，
但如果你能看得进去的话，
这篇小说会伴随你一辈子。
这个小说叫做平凡的世界，
有没有人看过的？
因为平凡的世界它描述的大概是那个年代的一些事儿和一些人的那个思想，
就是每个人的思想都在寻找自己的归宿，
都在混沌当中去探求他人生的出路，
他以后要怎么活着，
怎么成为那个自己。
付瑶老师写的，
我觉得就算现在我们经济条件好了，
可能有很多东西你很难沉下心来去看那么长篇的小说了，
但是如果有一天你实在百无聊赖了，
你实在觉得精神上有点荒芜了，
你给自己关起来，
你关起来一个星期，
你就看这样一部小说。
的话，
对现在的这个社会的看法会有另一番的视角，
对亲情，
对感情，
对命运都会有另一番视角。
我特别喜欢接地气儿的东西，
因为我始终觉得人就像是有一个神话里面的那个角色一样，
他需要接地气儿，
他才能源源不断的汲取生命中的养分。
有没有人能见得到我们菲姐这个点，
就像希腊里面有一个神话，
他有一个角色，
就是他必须脚站在大地上，
他才能赋予他的神力，
他才是无敌的，
他打谁他都不怵，
一旦你把它脱离了那个大地，
它就吸收不了那样的神力，
就谁都能弄死他。
我感觉我自己就有这种感受，
就是非常喜欢那些接地气儿的文字，
接地气儿的事儿，
刚刚有人说每年都会听一遍，
我有的时候像白鹿原啊，
我也是没事儿我就打开，
我就听一听，
平凡的世界也是没事儿我就打开，
我总能从这些我曾经看过的时候，
我曾经看过的一些影视作品当中，
我能觉到东西，
还能汲取到不同的养分，
不一样的力量。
刚刚有个朋友说的好，
说浅薄也挺好的，
活得快乐，
我真的那么想，
我就觉得我浅薄，
我承认我接纳我自己思想没有那么深刻，
接纳我自己的浅薄，
我感觉真的老快乐了，
他就怕什么呢？
就是你得装深沉，
你得装厚重，
你得装有文化，
这就挺难的，
有些人他可能平时不看书，
但是他得装的可有文化了，
装的可深度了，
我感觉那。
就挺别扭的，
就你自己别扭，
别人也别扭，
但像无非我这样的话，
就是我知道我浅薄，
我承认我浅薄，
我也接纳享受自己这个状态，
那就不一样了，
我还有一个事儿，
姐妹们非常关注我的形象，
我以前是个律师，
大家都知道啊，
但是我一直卖货嘛，
一直变现嘛，
但同时我的同行里面真的有那种一直咨询，
一直不卖货，
一直不变现的，
我其实发自内心来说的话，
我很尊重人家，
我觉得人家这个真的是有大爱啊，
或者说他可能通过这种方式，
他能有一点暗缘，
但他的变现的效率跟我比的话，
那确实是比不上我变现的效率，
因为我又回答问题，
然后我又卖货，
我又有佣金，
那我挣钱就要多一些，
是不是有很多声音在比较龙飞姐和别的不卖货的律师之间的高下，
就是显得不卖货的律师就更高尚，
龙飞姐就显得更俗气一点？
你们有没有看过这样的评价，
有看到过的扣1啊，
我也看到过，
我心想我的同行，
我也尊重他们啊，
他们不卖货，
我也尊重他们，
他们得到了好的名声，
龙飞得到了坏的名声，
可是我得到了钱，
就这两件事情让我选的话，
我依然会选择得到一个坏的名声，
但我得到了钱，
我依然不愿意选择说得到一个好的名声，
但没有得到很多的钱，
我得到很多的自由，
我得到了很多可以选择。
在哪生活的这个选择权，
我也得到了陪伴孩子的这个底气，
我讲这个逻辑，
我是希望我的姐妹们从这件事情当中明白一个事儿，
你在生活当中，
你也得明白自己想要什么，
如果你是那种十里八乡的好儿媳妇儿，
十里八乡的好姐姐，
给弟弟买房买车，
给弟弟置办这个置办那个，
你得到了好名声，
但是你得不到什么，
你得不到实实在在归属于你的该是你的利益。
像龙飞这样的，
我得到了坏名声，
但是我得到了实实在在的合法的利益，
谁能明白？
龙飞姐就想让我姐妹们学会的这个点，
就是在现实生活中，
你们在做决策的时候，
你到底是要做那个十里八乡的最孝顺的儿媳妇儿，
最好的姐姐，
最好的妈妈，
最好的老婆，
你还是要说，
我宁可我得一个坏名声，
但是我有实实在在的给我的孩子存了好多钱，
我实实在在的啊，
能够有更多的这个时间精力去教育陪伴引导我的孩子，
还是干嘛的，
你自己选。
龙飞姐我就打了个样，
我就是宁愿又有个坏名声，
但是我得到了实实在在的利益，
我得到了自由，
我得到了底气，
我得到了选择权。
记得点赞关注哦。